would you trade Joe burrow for any of
these QBs on this list from the Browns
no
any of the jerseys we can so many names
I got an hour and a half
I look like an essay but we're gonna try
to we're gonna try to get it the Power
Rangers the Power Rangers
I'm the Green Ranger we need some Paul
McDonald's I have no clue who that is
and George Ratterman
then I have more qvs than Chick-fil-A
got sausage
more money we got money man's out right
here we got this is this is this is
cousin right here we got Johnny all
right
oh there's Baker you think you should
have been traded I mean I like Baker but
you know I I'm I was a Brian horror guy
I haven't seen a jersey yet but if I
find one I'm a call for you we got one
down 59 more to go is that Baker
we got a bigger mate look they so tired
of Baker that they took the d off we're
gonna check Baker off right here I see a
Morgan but it's 81 that's not a that's
not a wait is that a two let me see wait
come on in there partner whose jersey is
that wait turn around we've got some
couch in the building let's go
wait is this a fresh Lake Erie bass
right here oh yeah so you're a clown
season ticket holder I'm just a season
ticket holder but are you saying you
look like a clown
[Music]
New York is that is that a QB
excuse me was York ever a quarterback it
was all right a quarterback no New York
all right no he's a kicker he's a kicker
yeah he's a kicker
[Music]
hey man can we I mean let me we're just
gonna check Bernie off have you guys
seen any weird ones uh any any old guys
we're looking for the old heads
Brandon Whedon go get it thank you let's
go talk to some weeding good to see you
my man great dude Brandon Whedon we
gotta cross them off the list number
three right here
Kevin coach the fanski right guys
what do we got over here birdie Kozar
let's go talk to her why are you wearing
the Bernie cozar I was gonna marry him
so wait so this is your second chance
with Bernie no this is my first chance
York every everybody loves this kicker
the kicker scores more points than the
QBs God damn it
oh damn see that's a receiver this is
all running backs
they're all running backs no no respect
for the QBs in Cleveland sir if your
mommy is this a QB this is me oh it's
you he'd rather put his own name on the
judges in the QB that's how you know
it's bad where's the weeding where's the
weeding
where
we got Brandon Wheaton is there a brand
new weed in Jersey
Tony
brand new we found them
all right let's check them off Brown's
Legend Brown's Legend if you had to give
some advice to the Browns tonight where
would you give them it's quite obvious
ly
we got 800 QBs and they want to run the
football we're trying to find all the
jerseys that Cleveland have had where's
buddy right there the joku no no no no
no no the the quarterbacks
couch we got couch we got it Tim Couch
Josie we got one we got a temp counts
right there let's check it off that's
right now let's check it off we got five
other other 800. it's not a quarterback
here we go Johnny Johnny Football hey
Johnny another I just you already got
another person surviving you so we might
be behind if Johnny was already back
Johnny man we suck
Jacoby said
we're set we got reset we got percent
why not support him right all right
is that
normally you have like one quarterback
for eight years
he get old you draft a new one every
goddamn year it's a new goddamn
quarterback we need one of those
scooters right now that's what we need
Williams greedy William oh
Colt McCoy is right over here
comikoi Texas goat baby could have been
what could have been there we go Colt
McCoy's down and I see you're rocking a
baker with a cloud it's just the baker
Mayfield custom Watson Mayfield AJ Green
Auto Graham
I'm trying to find every Browns
quarterback jersey and you are the auto
Graham I've been looking for I thank you
seven jerseys we're picking up the pace
here I'm starting to get a little more
confident but Jacoby Brissette where are
you dude you're the starting quarterback
Ryan site
Brett
got the Brian side Jersey yeah go Browns
go Brown we got a brad Hoyer Jersey
Brian we got a Brian Hoyas Jersey we got
it I think I'm gonna be coming out
Victorious this week I need to find as
many Brown's old quarterbacks as I can
find I can't find many who the [ __ ] is
George Ratterman
might have maxed out oh come on come on
come on
come on I'm getting a little it's about
the time right now I feel like we've
been stuck at seven for so long Luke can
have 15 bro I know but he can be sitting
at two five six seven eight we got nine
number eleven yeah the custom Jersey
yeah
it's a custom
Dorsey on the back of your jersey yeah
all right we got it oh man oh Lord we
got one 10 minutes left we're running
out of luck come on no one's wearing a
brassette jersey nobody there's a dude
over here there was a guy over here he's
ready
thank you give me some thank you
wait
we found it we found it oh my gosh can
you cross off to Kobe for me here
we're in Cleveland
come on damn right
is that Bernie cozar
we bout fry
he is the ninth jersey number nine
number nine number nine there's no
bright orange we found there's RG3
couldn't bite him we got a New Jersey
do we have Coach McCoy already we
already got Coke
how many did you get I got nine
nine single digits I know
I got Tim
I got 10. and that's how you do it I
came into the dog pound man and I took
control who'd you get all right so oh I
got sight
if I didn't get sight you got Jordans
how did you get Dorsey I didn't see a
single the legendary I went around I ran
four laps I ran four miles I was running
laps to get 10. and because I won kev's
got a challenge in honor of Cleveland's
own pumpkin head Super Fan Cav's gonna
be a pumpkin head all night in Cleveland
oh boy
oh gosh
take your ass out here
here we go brownies here we go